[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bon livre et
bonne lecture
parce que la lecture comme lundi dernier
daniel pennac dans comme un roman la
lecture est un acte de création
permanente
alors nous allons essayer de créer
ensemble avec des passionnés un qui
roule ou vous faire partager les livres
que nous avons aimés donc nous allons
commencer avec claire belles dents qui
est comédienne et chanteuse de grand
talent les judéo henri salvador
c'est pas facile et qui va nous parler
des gratitude par delphine de vigan
merci bernard
merci beaucoup dire merci dire merci à
temps c'est vraiment important et
parfois on n'a pas le temps de dire
merci et c'est bien dommage c'est ainsi
que je résumerais le livre de delphine
de vigan les gratitude
delphine de vigan a beaucoup écrit sur
les relations dans les familles sur les
relations profondes entre les êtres
humains les gratitude c'est l'histoire
d'une femme âgée michka qui rentre dans
un ehpad parce qu'elle est n'est plus
autonome
jérôme l'orthophoniste et marie une
jeune femme qui a été recueillie enfants
par michka vont raconter tour à tour
leur visite chez la vieille dame dans
l'ehpad
ces visites sont entrecoupées par les
cauchemars de michka quand lé sol et là
on comprend vraiment la solitude de ces
personnes qui se retrouvent dans ces
lieux sont pas du tout chez eux et quand
ils n'ont pas de visite ils sont
vraiment très très seule et on sent le
poids de cette solitude les moments qui
sont partagés
avec jérôme et marie ce sont des moments
tendres riche en émotions et bien que
mich cac perd ses mots se trompe de mots
on comprend toujours parfaitement ce
qu'elle veut dire et en fait ça m'a fait
penser à la pièce de théâtre de jean
tardieu un mot pour un autre en en fait
c'est le para verbale c'est l'expression
qui permet de comprendre ce que les
comédiens ont à dire et d'ailleurs ce
roman qui se passe dans un seul lieu la
chambre de michka avec uniquement trois
personnages jérôme l'orthophonie ce mari
et mishka pourrait très bien être adapté
au théâtre comme de couze
oui c'est vrai qu'on imagine ce que cet
homme tout à fait michka quand elle
était bébé a été recueilli par un couple
et elle a été sauvée de la déportation
et en fait elle n'a pas eu le temps de
remercier les personnes qui l'ont sauvé
et là elle ne peut plus rien faire elle
est enfermée dans cet ehpad et c'est
jérôme qui va rechercher les personnes
il va retrouver la maman d'adoption et
c'est lui qui va être le messager
de la reconnaissance de michka voilà et
ensuite
mais jusqu'à va pouvoir s'endormir
paisiblement merci clair donc on va
essayer de redécouvrir des films de
maintenant monicault dominiak qui est
auteur et conteuse va nous parler de
l'afrique qu'elle aime tellement nous
aussi avec afrique petit chacun oui
alors je vous le montre ce livre est
magnifique
les illustrations aussi c'est tous les
tons qu'ils sont propres à l'afrique
alors c'est en fait là les changes d'un
grand père et de son petit fils soit
l'afrique qui se sait et lui pose des
questions à lui dit ni papa d'un beau je
vais je vais vous lire quelques passages
parce que c'est je pense que j'ai un peu
le temps de se ressourcer les
illustrations sont superbes vient
d'abord il dit papa d'ambo est un grand
écran comme le baobab et plus avant que
le marabout papa d'ambo et mon
grand-père et il raconte des histoires
mieux que personne
il lui dit papa dans body mois de quelle
quelle est la couleur de l'afrique
l'afrique petit chacun elle est noir
comme à pau elle est rouge comme la
terre elle est blanche comme la lumière
de midi elle est bleue comme nombre du
soir elle est jaune comme le grand
fleuve
elle est verte comme la feuille de
palmier l'afrique petit chacun à toutes
les couleurs de la vie est chère fois
poser question papa d'hambourg elle est
là qu qu'elle a la couleur d'afrique
après lui demande il eut deux il lui
demande de parler de son enfance de sa
mère de son père aya passage sur la mer
j'aime beaucoup qu'on peut dire parce
que au moins elle tient toute la place
dans la culture africaine c'est très
bien tu as déjà ma mère petit chat cas
n'est pas restée longtemps mince comme
une liane après mois treize autres sont
venus 6 filles et 7 garçons à le vacarme
dans la case pire qu'une tools de
macaques aux folies mais elle khadija ma
mère jamais je n'ai entendu aussi à la
voix elle était calme comme l'arachide
est belle toujours dans ses boubous
aussi coloré que les fleurs de la savane
si belle que de toutes les femmes de
samba mon père
elle a toujours été la mieux aimer alors
ça c'est une reconnaissance que je
trouve formidable
alors il parle il parle de deux du
village là d'une journée que type du
fleuve
tu fais et à et petit à petit ils
arrivent sur les grands thèmes de
l'afrique là le problème de la pluie la
brousse les esprits est tout un passage
sur les esprits et les esprits de la
nuit la magie la circoncision qu'elle
était d'aborder de façon très très très
très belle les ancêtres et la mort juste
ce petit passage je lui dis papa d'un
beau jamais je veux que tu meurt jamais
la mort petit chacun à la mort est un
vêtement que tout le monde portera
mais demain est encore loin et j'ai
devant moi des jours des mois des années
pour te raconter d'autres histoires qui
te feront garder dans le coeur à la
mémoire de l'afrique
et peut-être que plus tard quand tu
auras mon âge petit chacun à ton tour tu
raconteras à ton petit fils les
histoires de papa d'ambo alors oh je
serai je rêverais de bonheur et là je
retrouve le petit prince un petit peu
voilà je suis amoureuse de ce livre et
je vous conseille de le de de le lire ce
petit écran pour les petit à petit les
grands tout à fait en fait il était dans
un très grand format et intérêts a été
réduit ma médias toujours source au
charme ou et peut-être que vous faut que
je dise marie marie sellier et marion
lesage etc et c'est la maison d'édition
jeunesse
on a du mal à le trouver mon trouve
voilà même si le mot dico pour ce voyage
en afrique
nathalie et le bold etc et maître de
conférences à l'université de 50 ans
divine tout à côté à nous parler
maintenant d'une brève éternité de
pascale bruderer
oui tout à fait merci bernard alors j'ai
choisi de vous parler de ce livre donc
une vraie d'éternité avec un sous titre
qui s'intitule philosophie
éviter parce que c'est une injonction à
ne jamais renoncer
c'est presque une ode à la vie donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu aujourd'hui
vous présenter ce livre qui va sortir
ces jours ci en septembre mon pascal
bruckner on ne présente plus c'est un
philosophe un romancier qui a écrit plus
d'une trentaine de livres et donc il
nous revient cet automne avec un essai
qui part du constat suivant on a gagné
30 ans de vie d'espérance de vie depuis
1900 d'ailleurs 30 ans c'était la
totalité de l'existence d'une personne
d'un homme ou d'une femme au xviie
siècle et donc c'est une formidable
avancée qui va tout bouleverser la vie
familiale la vie amoureuse à des
professionnels qui tout simplement le
rapport au monde est donc l'auteur on
posa la question suivante alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de ces trente années
de sursis de ce cadeau ambigus comme il
écrit
et au fond il pose la question de savoir
comment aborder cette période un peu
spécifique ou après 50 ans bah on n'est
plus tout à fait jeune et puis on n'est
pas vraiment vieux non plus donc c'est
ça qui est intéressant dans ce livre
c'est laborde de cette période
particulière et ils se demandent au fond
le sait vraiment ce à l'objet du livre
comment convertir cette vie en plus en
un art de vivre
c'est vraiment un livre un homme qui a
pour objet l'art de vivre alors moi j'ai
trouvé que ce qui m'a beaucoup plu dans
ce livre c'est qu'il ya des analystes
qui se montrent très percutante
notamment sur le renoncement et même sur
le renoncement en renoncement des choses
assez original à peu à contre-courant
sur la vertu de la routine de la
répétition sur la maladie bien sûr sur
la mort mais surtout c'est le coeur du
livre sur le désir puisque le désir ne
disparaît pas en vieillissant et je
crois que c'est un peu le message du
livre s'il ya du désir en toute chose
mais c'est peut-être ça qui peut nous
sauver
alors ce que j'ai trouvé également bien
fait dans ce livre c'est que on va être
presque dans une balade philosophique et
littéraire donc pour mener sa à son
analyse réflexion il nous emmène de
homer en passant par dix veille
maupassant sartre toute la littérature
étrangère il convoque les arts la
musique la peinture le cinéma et c'est à
dire qu'on a un livre qui est très riche
mais très accessible
parce qu'on a une écriture comme ça très
limpide donc c'est très très abordable
en dépit de cette fin de cette richesse
et il ya toujours des formules comme
dans tous ses livres très savoureuse
voilà sinon terminer cette émission en
compagnie d'evelyne dresse et vendres
est tout le monde se souvient de
l'héroïne est la tendresse bordel
patrick schulmann où les tec bernard
giraudeau qui a disparu trop tôt mais
donc pas d'amour sans amour et un bond
plus joindre à ce sera aussi au salon de
lyon court comme invité d'honneur le
dimanche 24 novembre salon présidée par
patrice franceschi
evelyne dress sera aussi invité
d'honneur donc si vous voulez des livres
dédicacés pro freinerait nous faudra
donc dans pas d'amour sans amour
retrouvé un peu le personnage de c'est
peut-être la suite de la tendresse
bordel où elle s'appelait va là on
retrouve elle va donc qu'une femme
célibataire de 40 ans une jeune femme
dynamique branché ça se passe dans les
années 90 mais le sortant seul a été
déçu par lés c'est ce contact
sentimentaux les hommes sont parfois
décevant par utile
et donc par son dernier compagnon elle
est de vous les faire un enfant lui ne
voulait pas donc voilà elle a en fait à
cause de ça qu'après il va lui arriver
de plein d'aventurés enfin de tomber sur
du type bizarre tout ça elle cherche le
l'amour fusionnel quoi avec du sentiment
est aussi
cherche le type idéal quoi qui est
difficile à trouver elle nous emmène
dans plein de davanture tout ça s'écrit
avec beaucoup d'humour beaucoup d'humour
aussi la lucidité
c'est vraiment très intéressant et le
début ça de ça démarre très fort est
laissé son gynécologue
le wef voilà alors reçu peu voulurent
quelques phrases je pose les fesses sur
le bord de la table et les jambes en
l'air
j'enfonce les étriers avec la volonté
d'écarter les cuisses aller décrocher de
mon bassin mais inégaux lognes plonge
loin dans mes entrailles méthodes
archaïques à l'heure où l'humanité fait
des pas de géant sur la lune je ne me
plains pas je suis une femme émancipée
me retrouvais béante devant un inconnu
ne me gêne pas
tout à l'heure dans la salle d'attenté
une jeune femme disait à son mari je ne
rentre pas si tu ne viens pas avec moi
sapeurs se mêler à la digne à sion de
partager avec un inconnu
ce qu'elles donnent chaque soir à
l'homme qu'elle aime si je n'étais pas
émancipés
je ne le pense je la comprendrais doyer
femme libérée depuis la chanson de
cookie dingler la de strasbourg et il
fallut garros et que c'est pas facile
et dans ce livre
elle montre de façon humoristique et
lucide aussi avec beaucoup d'humour que
c'est pas facile qu auraient ils parlent
des femmes avec beaucoup de gentillesse
il se trouve je suis au milieu de cinq
soeurs je suis une famille de 8
j'étais entouré de cinq soeurs on doit
avoir un autre homme
mais il est tombé malade c'est patrick
ottaviani qu'un éditeur écrivain il est
tombé malade et voilà on lui souhaite un
bon rétablissement
non merci
[Musique]